Fue casi dos años después
cuando me di cuenta de cómo debía llamarse esa persona.
Estaba dando una charla en la Universidad de Michigan
a los candidatos a MBA,
hablando sobre lo que había aprendido
después de mi tres cortos años en Wall Street,
y de repente caí.
Dije: "Oh, esta persona que vela por sus intereses,
o como a mí me gusta decir, que lleva tu papel a la sala,
esta persona que está gastando
su valioso capital político y social en uno,
esa persona que va a golpear la mesa en tu defensa
es un promotor.
Es un promotor".
Y luego me dije a mí misma:
"Vale, ¿cómo se obtiene un promotor?
Y sinceramente, ¿para qué se necesita uno?".
Pues sinceramente, se necesita un promotor
porque como pueden ver,
que yo sepa no hay un solo proceso evaluativo,
ya sea en el ámbito académico, en el sanitario o en servicios financieros,
no hay ni uno que no tenga un elemento humano.
Eso significa que tiene la medida de la subjetividad.
Hay una medida de subjetividad en quién presenta su caso.
Hay una medida de subjetividad
en lo que dicen
y en cómo interpretan cualquier dato objetivo que uno pueda tener.
Hay una medida de subjetividad en cómo dicen lo que van a decir
para influenciar el resultado.
Así que tienen que asegurarse de que la persona que va a hablar,
ese promotor,
de verdad desee su mayor beneficio
y tenga el poder de conseguirlo, sea lo que sea para uno,
para hacerlo a puerta cerrada.
Constantemente me preguntan:
"¿Cómo consigues uno?"
La verdad, el nirvana es cuando alguien te ve en un entorno
y decide "voy a hacer que le suceda.
Voy a asegurarme de que tenga éxito".
Pero muchos de nosotros en esa sala sabemos que en realidad no funciona así.
Así que déjenme presentarles el concepto de beneplácito
y hablarles sobre cómo afecta a su capacidad de conseguir un promotor.
Hay dos tipos de beneplácito en cualquier entorno:
beneplácito de rendimiento y beneplácito de relaciones.
El beneplácito del rendimiento es el beneplácito que se genera
cuando entregan lo que se les han pedido
y un poquito más.
Cada vez que entregan un encargo por encima de las expectativas de la gente
generan beneplácito de rendimiento.
Funciona igual que el mercado de valores.
Cada vez que una empresa dice al público
que darán 25 centavos por acción
y esa empresa da 40 centavos por acción
esas acciones suben, y las suyas también.
El beneplácito de rendimiento es valioso por tres motivos.
Número uno, hará que se fijen en Uds.
Les creará una reputación.
Número dos, también hará que les paguen y los asciendan
muy pronto en su trabajo
y muy pronto en cualquier entorno.
Y número tres, puede atraer a algún promotor.
¿Por qué? Porque un beneplácito de fuerte rendimiento
aumenta su nivel de visibilidad en ese entorno, como he dicho antes,
de manera que un promotor puede sentirse atraído por Uds.
¿Por qué? Porque todo el mundo adora a una estrella.
Pero si se encuentran en una situación
en la que no tienen un promotor
tengo buenas noticias.
Recuerden que pueden ejercer su poder y pedir uno.
Pero aquí es donde el otro beneplácito es más importante.
El beneplácito en las relaciones,
que es el que se genera
por las inversiones que hacen en la gente de su entorno,
las inversiones que hacen en la gente de su entorno.
No pueden pedir a alguien que utilice su bien ganado
beneplácito de popularidad personal en su nombre
si nunca han interactuado con ellos.
No va a pasar.
Así que es importante que inviertan tiempo en conectar, en hablar
y en conocer a la gente de su entorno,
y lo que es más importante, darles la oportunidad de que los conozcan.
Porque una vez que los conozcan,
habrá una mayor probabilidad de que cuando se acerquen a ellos
para pedirles que sean su promotor,
respondan que sí.
Si son como yo y están de acuerdo en que hay que tener un promotor,
hablemos sobre cómo identificar a uno.
Si están buscando un promotor
deben tener tres características básicas.
Número uno, tienen que tener un lugar en la mesa en la que se toman decisiones,
tienen que estar expuestos a su trabajo
para tener credibilidad a puerta cerrada,
y tienen que tener influencia,
o por decirlo de otra manera, más les vale tener algo de poder.
Es muy importante que tengan esas tres cosas.
Y una vez que hayan identificado a esa persona,
¿cómo se lo piden?
El guion es algo así.
"Jim, me interesa mucho que me ascendieran este año.
He tenido un año increíble
y no hay nada más que pueda enseñar a esta empresa para demostrar que valgo
o que estoy listo para un ascenso,
pero también soy consciente de que tiene que haber alguien a puerta cerrada
que pelee por mi beneficio y de un golpe sobre la mesa.
Me conoce, conoce mi trabajo y conoce la retroalimentación de los clientes
y espero que se sienta a gusto discutiendo en mi nombre".
Si Jim los conoce
y tienen algún tipo de relación
hay una probabilidad muy alta de que diga que sí,
y si dice que sí,
se esforzará en sacarlo adelante.
Pero cabe la posibilidad de que Jim diga que no,
y si dice que no, en mi opinión,
solo hay tres razones por las que diría que no.
La primera es que crea que no conoce su trabajo lo suficiente
como para tener credibilidad real a puerta cerrada
para impactar y ser efectivo en su nombre.
La segunda razón por la que puede decir que no
es que Uds. piensan que tiene influencia para conseguirlo,
pero él sabe que no tiene poder para hacerlo
y no va admitirlo delante de Uds.
(Risas)
Y la tercera razón por la que diría que no
es que Ud. no le agrada.
Ud. no le agrada.
(Risas)
Y eso es algo que podría pasar.
Pero hasta eso sería información valiosa para Ud.
que le ayudará en su siguiente conversación con un promotor
y puede que le haga tener algo más de impacto.
No les puedo decir lo importante que es tener un promotor.
Es la relación fundamental en sus trabajos.
Sinceramente, es agradable tener un mentor,
pero se puede sobrevivir mucho tiempo profesionalmente sin uno,
pero no van a ascender en ninguna organización sin un promotor.
Es tan fundamental que deberían preguntarse con frecuencia:
"¿Quién va a llevar mis papeles a la sala?
¿Quién va a llevar mis papeles a la sala?".
Y si no pueden contestar esa pregunta
les diré que desvíen parte de su energía de su trabajo duro
hacia la inversión en una relación con un promotor,
porque será fundamental para su éxito.
Para terminar, déjenme decirles algo
a los futuros promotores que están en aquí.
Si los han invitado a la sala,
sepan que tienen un sitio en la mesa,
y si tienen un sitio en la mesa
tienen la responsabilidad de hablar.
No gasten su poder preocupándose por lo que va a decir la gente
o por si piensan o no que pueden estar apoyando a alguien
simplemente porque son como Uds.
Si alguien es digno de su beneplácito,
díganlo.
Una de las cosas que he aprendido tras varias décadas en Wall Street
es que la manera de hacer crecer su poder es repartiéndolo
y sus voces son muy importantes.
(Aplausos)
Sus voces son lo más importante de su poder.
Úsenlas.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)